le prochain gouvernement du canada sera
minoritaire
ce n'est jamais le scénario idéal du
moins pour le parti qui forment le
gouvernement sache incroyable parce que
on est toujours on a toujours l'épée de
damoclès christian paradis a été
ministre sous stephen harper il a connu
le règne minoritaires une toute autre
façon de gouverner que lorsqu'un parti
remporte la majorité des sièges on sait
qu'elle va m'avoir survivent parce que
c'est quand même planifié avec les
partis d'opposition mais n'en reste pas
moins faut se présenter à chaque fois
qu'un vote de confiance faut être là la
vie parlementaire au delà juste des
projets de loi et des votes enchante
change beaucoup beaucoup
y aura-t-il une vague bloquiste demain
comme celle que la libérale hélène
scherrer a connu en 2004
à la fin quand on voit les résultats on
est toujours déçu après avoir perdu son
siège l'ancien ministre est travaillé
dans les coulisses du gouvernement
minoritaire de paul martin je voudrais
surtout leur rythme change parce que
c'est beaucoup plus long j'apprends déjà
les convenances faut accepter le fait
qu' on peut pas dépendre notre entière
plateforme p d'ailleurs ces choix de la
population
donc il faut s'entendre s'entendre avec
les partis comme le bloc québécois
les verts ou encore le npd ceux qui
détiendront la balance du pouvoir et
donc qu'ils ont plus de poids que sous
un gouvernement majoritaire
c'est très intéressant passage en hausse
+ écoute plus ils doivent s'ils veulent
rester en place
négocier son à voter pour le bloc
québécois peut-être que l'eau justement
c'est plus intéressant en parlement avec
un grand minolta parce que notre parti
en plus d' influence législatives mais
un gouvernement minoritaire est il
forcément moins efficace il la réponse
est un peu moins sans grande surprise on
va on va au moins trois projets de lois
d'envergure adopté la durée de vie
moyenne d'un gouvernement minoritaire
est de 21 mois presque deux ans donc
avant qu'un vote de confiance le faire
tomber et que le pays retourne en
élections issigeac audrey charbonneau
rade canada mon frère